so siegen is a homeware and furniture
brand olivia lee studio is a
multi-disciplinary studio we are being
emerged out of wahawa
architects which is a firm that's been
in existence for 25 years we're a
singapore company
and we're inspired by a rich asian
heritage and culture
and we try to take that to make it a bit
more contemporary so that it's more
suitable for urban homes of today we
work on very diverse projects
from product design to retail design but
also
design research and art direction we
actually developed a very large
back catalogue of furniture and objects
we knew there was a demand for waha
products but they weren't available in
the market
so we set up workout beam as a mechanism
to bring these products to market
so one of the consultants we were paired
with under the business of design
program was
nathan young and right from the start we
had very
open and transparent communication with
each other where he
um identified what our pain points were
throughout the program we actually got
to
see an end-to-end holistic approach to
what we can do with our brand
rather than just being very specific to
design a collection for example
our studio was linked with tony chambers
as our in-market
consultant his insights and his advice
are particularly nuanced to our sector
and he's able to bring a perspective
that marries
both what our creative understands and
also the business
context of our industry our consultant
retub
is based in italy and very familiar with
the whole supply chain in italy
the specialist manufacturers the way
products are
marketed and supplied to retailers
and not just in furniture but across the
whole design spectrum the business
of design program has presented an
opportunity for us that maybe on our own
or as a starting brand we would not have
even thought of pursuing you know a
consultant or
or an in-market expert in this area
could always ask from these consultants
who have
had all these years of experience and
can sort of steer us in
in the direction that they think would
be beneficial for us
my trip to europe was a woman affair
in one week we went to copenhagen paris
and stockholm
with the benefit of tony's network that
we were able to meet with many
high-level executives we never thought
we'd have the opportunity to meet
and most valuably it was these in-depth
conversations and face-to-face sessions
that are so critical for relationship
building in working with the business of
design consultant
we had a really useful epiphany where
what we thought was our difficulty
perhaps or something that was
hard to explain which was we were an
architectural practice that we're now
moving into product design
we at xinshang believe that sincha is a
way of life it's not just furniture and
homeware
so through this program we actually have
allowed this vision to to come
become more real for us we found a maker
partner who actually had
the technical expertise and experience
in making return furniture
uh return aluminium and other
sustainable woven materials
so from this we actually designed this
whole collection made of these new
materials creating a whole new
product offering so through working with
the consultant i think we have a very
professional and business friendly
outcome and we're looking forward once
covid is over
being able to meet with potential
partners and move or harveying into its
next phase
after going through the business of
design program we have quite a different
idea of the future of waiha being
we are very clear now that we can focus
on doing what we love
which is creating unique designs often
located in a particular project or
location
and with a very clear customer and now
with the
reconceptionalisation of the business we
can really focus on that
so we see ourselves in the future doing
what we love and doing what we enjoy
making more designs and hopefully
generating income
through our licensing business of what
happening
i think for anyone you know interested
to join the business of design program
i think it's really important that
studio practice
already has some sort of vision for
themselves and to think of bod like an
accelerator of where they see themselves
it
is a program that that gives as much as
you put into it as well
it's a dialogue it's not a one-way
solution i think that covert definitely
has affected the
plans for expansion globally we can't
just go to the old trade shows like
before
so actually what nathan has done is that
he's introduced us to business contacts
overseas
and we've met them through zoo meetings
and actually the zoo meetings have been
quite productive in meeting
people that we would not have met
otherwise it could be also different
ways of working like for example
getting us to design a collection for
business partners overseas
and getting the items we produced in
china itself we founded wahawa being
to create delightful meaningful ethical
objects
our dream for waha being is we find a
wonderful licensing partner
who will help us share these objects
with the world i think through what
we've learned
we've seen that there is a clear and
growing appetite and need
for poetry wonder and romance
and design not just in europe but also
asia too
[Music]
you